kim kardashian is showing her support
for britney spears
and recalling her own experience with
tabloid culture
and body shaming it's so hard on friday
the reality star took to instagram to
reveal how she felt
after recently watching the new york
times documentary framing britney spears
dear brittany dear britney dear baby why
is she still in this why is her dad
making all of her decisions i have
always viewed the situation as something
that i don't think would have ever
happened to a man in america
first kim defends brittany writing quote
the way the media played a big role in
her life the way it did can be very
traumatizing and it can really break
even the strongest person
no matter how public someone's life may
seem no one deserves to be treated with
such cruelty
or judgment for entertainment i mean
that's that's a lot
the mom of four explains how watching
the documentary compelled her to reflect
on her own experiences with the media
specifically 2013 when she was pregnant
with her eldest daughter
north west kim writes that she suffered
from preeclampsia that made her swell
and gained 60 pounds
she says cruel stories written about her
body and the tabloids made her cry
every single day i was shamed on a
weekly basis with cover stories that
made my insecurities so painful
i couldn't leave the house for months
after it really broke me
kim says she was thankfully able to
channel the toxicity into motivation
and became the business mogul we know
today but still she adds to say this
didn't take a toll on me mentally would
be a lie
a sentiment she shared with e.t in 2013.
i think because of so much media
scrutiny
it really motivated me actually to want
to
really stick and commit to something now
the kkw beauty founder is encouraging
her followers to show
understanding and compassion writing you
just never fully know what someone is
going through behind the scenes and i've
learned through my own experiences that
it's always better to lead with kindness
kim is the latest star to publicly come
forward in brittany's defense
john mayer miley cyrus and drew
barrymore have all shown their support
meanwhile justin timberlake who dated
britney in the early 2000s came under
fire following the documentary's release
for the role he played in the aftermath
of their split he issued a public
apology to brittany in february that
read in part quote
i know i failed i also feel compelled to
respond in part because everyone
involved deserves better
and most importantly because this is a
larger conversation that i
wholeheartedly
want to be a part of and grow from kelly
rowland's rise to fame and destiny's
child came at the same time as britney's
here's what she said about the
documentary on thursday's watchword
happens live with andy cohen
i haven't seen the brittany doc i'm
having a hard time like in
wanting to watch it um just because i
really respect the fact like when
artists actually
say this is a documentary it's okay to
watch this
you know what i mean i respect you know
their space
and their privacy and their point of
view